- So, I'm not sure if
you're familiar with him,
but Andrew Yang is a
presidential candidate
currently running.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- With MATH in all capital
letters on his hats as a slogan.
- [Interviewer] I see!
- It stands for Make America Think Hard.
- Okay, I'll vote for him.
(laughing)
- So, and his name rhymes
with yours, Yang Strang.
So, but he also loves Math,
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- And then he comes from that world of...
- [Interviewer] Right.
- But, he also,
looking at it,
makes me realize that Math,
Science and Engineering,
are not really part of our politics.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Political discourse,
about political like,
government in general.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- Why do you think that is?
Well, what are your
thoughts on that in general?
- Well, certainly somewhere in the system,
we need people who are
comfortable with numbers,
comfortable with quantities, you know.
If you say this leads to that they see it.
It's undeniable.
- But isn't that strange to you that
we have almost no, I mean,
I'm pretty sure we have no
elected officials in Congress
or obviously the President.
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- That either has an Engineering
degree or a Math degree.
- Yeah, well, that's too bad.
You know, a few could,
a few who could make the connection, yeah?
It would have to be people who are,
who are, who understand
Engineering or Science,
and at the same time, can make speeches,
and, and lead.
Yeah,
- Inspire people.
- Yeah, inspire, yeah.